well the first 30 minutes of this movie
is a better fall from grace due to
bashed loved and the entirety of the
Star Wars prequels could dude you got
like something like that
Maleficent the Maleficent is the story
of Maleficent news otherwise known as
the bad chick is Sleeping Beauty whose
head looks like nickel bolus his head
let that sink in cuz that's totally true
this movie is here to give us a little
bit of insight it's like maybe she
wasn't just a big who wanted to
kill a kid oh my I like that concept too
I like the concept that there's these
Disney movies that I have in my DNA
because I saw them when I was a kid now
I can see live-action versions of them
that have kind of different spins on
them I just I like that in terms of
human beings who are living right now
Angelina Jolie is pretty much the best
pick to play Maleficent the first 30
minutes of this movie it's actually
pretty awesome it's a good setup
you see Maleficent when she was young
she was full of hope and then she just
kind of goes sour for her and after that
she has her big entrance she's like I
will curse look good no she didn't sound
like dr. Clough he smoked like I did
just now but the bummer was when she was
saying her lines and she curses the kid
I was like wait a minute
that's dis different than I remember I
don't remember everything about Sleeping
Beauty cuz I saw it when I was a kid but
as this movie was going along I was like
oh I'm just all flooding back to me
kind of weird how memories do that but
it was really coming back and I was like
no that's different because I remember
in the Sleeping Beauty animation she was
like before the Sun sets on her 16th
birthday she will prick her finger on
the spindle of a spinning wheel and die
I remember that when I was kid I was
like yeah that's Willy Grimm in this one
she's like before the Sun sets on her
16th birthday she will prick her finger
on the spindle of a spinning wheel and
sleep it looked like she's dead but
don't worry kid she won't be dead we're
not gonna kill her in a rated PG movie
made for you if there's any blood movie
don't worry it's just ketchup it really
took me out of it I was like in what
world do we live in were the animation
the cartoon had the balls to say
something that the movie didn't just say
she'll be dead it just makes it a little
more interesting you feel like the
stakes are high like oh this movie the
stakes are high because what she gets to
sleep in now
that's any teenagers dream and at a
point in this movie after Aurora's grown
up you see Angelina Jolie and at a point
you're like it's Maleficent she's kind
of nice to this girl and she's kind of
it was weird because you're like do you
hate her
not just make up your mind that wasn't
the irritating thing because I know that
she's you know supposed to make her feel
at home and maybe I do care about human
beings but she was playing these little
parlor tricks she went from being pretty
much the devil incarnate to be like hell
when it throw your hat off kind of
reminded me when they nerfed the Joker
in the comic books after they couldn't
kill people anymore like I is a Clown
Prince of Crime he just kind of zaps
people and maybe a boxing level come out
of his little flower it just it was
trickery it's just not as bad as really
evil magic that's green Charlotte oak
Oakley plays the king in this movie he
was really good as the king he started
losing his mind at a point you're like
this is this is the darkest part of the
movie right here it's nothing to do with
Maleficent is this guy he is really
losing his in the movie he goes
batshit crazy about one reel away from
having Jaime Lannister stabbed him in
the back he's pretty bad I like that I
like the fact that the Kings losing his
mind because he's so obsessed with
Maleficent what I didn't like is the
fact that they bring this Prince into
the movie because the prince has to be
in the movie because it has a princess
and you know we knew that there was a
prince in the story but in this one the
movies taken such liberties here and
there that do we really need a prince
the answer's no we really didn't need
the Prince because the print is so
shoehorned into this movie you're like I
haven't met you before and shits about
to go down who are you did you get lost
from the other set of filming something
else that's not this movie why are you
here
and the movie just wraps up in this nice
little bow they could have just upped
the stakes it could have made the ending
a lot better I mean I'm gonna use better
at a vague reference so I don't spoil
for you I'm just saying the ending
was so nice and tidy I'm like it's a
movie about a villain you could have
done one of a hundred things it would be
more impactful in this ending I'm not
looking for the deepest movie efforts of
Disney live-action remake I'm not
expecting to go home driving home be
like hmm oh so many layers what does it
mean but a movie where the villain is
the main character you could have a
better ending than the nice little tidy
ending that this movie is there were
certain situations in this movie that
they never lasted like oh that's really
Bo don't worry it's gone now that would
have been really dire if I felt it would
last a little bit it's an hour and a
half long just don't wanna bore people
so ultimately the movie is about the
villain and I liked the villain I like
Angelina Jolie as Maleficent I like the
fact that they gave Maleficent character
it ultimately concentrates on her and
she's like hey this is my side of the
story maybe I'm not a dick maybe I am
but maybe a
still am but maybe I'm not always maybe
I am though but as long as we all
understand her dictum by the time we
leave the theater I feel like the movie
did his job surprisingly enough though
even though the movie was sloppily paced
in parts I will say Maleficent was a
good time Navarro required for what it
was which is a live-action rated PG
remake for kids and families free to
show your favorite Disney villain of all
time I might have asked you that before
but that's always an interesting
question whoever it is comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more